they're digging for water
having to scoop holes in the sand until
waist deep to try to get to the water
table
and there are thousands doing this on
what was once a river and not a small
one at that it's the starkest image of
how severely climate change is affecting
madagascar and from our drone pictures
the snaking sand scar goes on and on and
on
they dig because there is no water this
is all they have for drinking washing
cooking after the worst extended drought
in 40 years
and this is a country which basically
gets around on this carts not many of
them in comparison to the population
have access to cars they don't even have
access to electricity only about 15
of the country have access to
electricity so they're one of the lowest
emitters of carbon
emissions in the world and yet they are
the country which is
really feeling the most impact with the
un declaring that parts of the country
are on the brink of tipping into famine
climate change is killing and malala is
one of madagascar's younger victims
she's barely got the strength to turn
her head she's the weight of a typical
newborn she's actually a year and two
months old with few reserves to fight
disease
she's now got tuberculosis but is too
weak to cry and protest very much
she's living and slowly dying in the
country likely to go down in history as
the first to suffer from a climate
change famine
the health workers have few weapons to
fight this environmental war
and without a shot being fired they're
seeing suffering on a huge scale and
they are losing with the bulk of the
country so poor they're struggling to
get enough to eat
the weekly clinic in above is crowded
with mothers and hungry children with
acute malnutrition
here a swollen stomach is the sign of
suffering and hunger nearly 90 percent
of the country live below the poverty
line earning less than two dollars a day
they're one of the poorest countries in
the world
[Music]
crying's a good sign it means the little
girl's strong enough to fight and a
small victory she's gained weight
her mother smiles for the first time
i'm very happy she tells us
[Music]
the young are the most vulnerable
madagascar is battling after years of
failed or poor crops caused by this
extended dry period
and this aid is their only hope of
survival
they give thanks to the aid agencies the
lack of water has had a knock-on effect
with poor sanitation increasing and
ramping up disease
every day's a fight to eat and to live
and these are the ones who've made it to
the main southern city and help
we travel through the south the worst
hit region the country's one of the most
bio-diverse in the world with a unique
ecosystem and species not found anywhere
else on earth but it's now struggling
there's very little infrastructure with
mostly unpaved roads and many
communities extremely remote so what aid
there is is difficult to deliver the
extreme weather includes multiple yearly
cyclones and dust storms making
subsistence farming even tougher and
people are becoming more and more
desperate
these young herdsmen didn't want to be
interviewed
but picking up rocks and waving their
farming tools they demand money to let
us through
and then sit down in front of our
vehicles and refuse to budge until we do
our malagasy colleagues begin
negotiations as the herdsmen tell them
they're hungry and they need money for
food our drivers reluctantly hand over
cash
when we reach marofu the village elder
in orange is appalled at the attempted
hold up raids on the meager crops are on
the rise here
he's anxious to show us how malnourished
the children are and many are showing
signs of acute malnutrition
this is what they've been reduced to
eating cactus flowers which are devoured
very quickly they offer some relief from
hunger pangs but they will bloat their
bellies and cause cramps later
many have blistered lips and the wizard
skin of those three times their age
of course these are not enough for us
but we've no choice hariba tells us
no one has electricity here they cut
trees and burn wood for fuel so many
live in medieval conditions
and two large families with a total of
16 children to feed
[Music]
i can't ever fill these bowls with
enough food for them he says and we're
always hungry but i watered the rice
down to make it go further
he shows us his second home a few yards
away he's trying to make stuffing for
mattresses
but he's not sold anything so they'll
eat cactus flowers again he says
the village elder insists on escorting
us out his instincts are correct the
herdsmen have been waiting for us to
leave on the single track out the young
men are scolded as they protest they
need help
everyone is hungry
madagascar has contributed virtually
nothing to the world's annual carbon
emissions but is probably the worst
affected country and its people are
crying out for change alex crawford sky
news madagascar